all i know is this kanye highland me bro
we got part two on the laptop ain't
never been seen we'd love for you to
have it it'd be a great personal private
nft you know wait wait wait wait wait so
there's another
ray j kim k sex tape that's that we
haven't seen yeah that was more graphic
and better than the first one was it
ever going to see the light of day i
mean i wouldn't meet personally i would
never give it to anybody but kanye
because that's
he's got ki it's a mother is children
it's a lot of people that didn't try to
reach for that for a price tag obviously
kanye could buy it from you or would you
just give it to him say what i i
probably would because it's kanye i i
probably would give it to kanye because
it's kanye is ray j in the same mind
state as you because that's my little
brother you know he made we might wake
up one day and radius like [ __ ] it nah
nah because you know onlyfans.com
remember ray j's a father now too yes
yes yes you understand what i'm saying
so and ray j really ain't a boss he's a
you know he's a great he's a great guy
so you know that's i think we would
probably gift that to him
you don't know saying if whatever that
day was to come we was just saying we
would give that to him he got money he
got children by that one you've seen the
part two i mean we've been in our life
ten eleven twelve so you've seen the
unreleased
kim kors what do you mean
wow and it was better than the first one
longer all that
wow
hey well listen
uh kanye tapping with whack 100 yeah
we'll gift that to him we you know
that's that's for him you know i mean we
can't put that out there in the world
like that be disrespectful